bravo nicolas gill très contente pour me
collard mes yeux bon je déplore que dans
cette catégorie scénario il n'y avait
qu'une seule femme nommée sur sur cinq
nommés voilà et j'espère que ça va
changer comme vous tous je trouve qu'il
ya encore trop de discriminations dans
le cinéma y aider il ya même des
catégories qui ne sont absolument pas
représenté 1 au cinéma et pourtant ils
sont un million et demi en france
les chats bah ouais mais non je ce qu'on
en parle je veux dire il n'y a pas cette
chasse dans le cinéma français en ca du
clébard bazire et on a rendu rintintin
du beethoven du mil ou la belle et
sébastien lui l'idée fixe du but du
boule et bill pas du boulou du bild
ailleurs je sais pas mais contraint
garfield est encore mal comme par hasard
de type caucasien encore encore mezzés
ou shot quoi je suis désolé ça manque de
chaque dans le cinéma français ne sont
pas oui mais vous pensez aux chats qui
sont devant leur écran il n'y a personne
pour ils peuvent pas s'identifier tu
comprends guy qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
venir verront sont réduits les pouvoir
faire des pauvres vidéo sur youtube
faire semblant la peur d'un concombre ou
tombé d'une rare bird fenêtre pour
essayer d'exister
j'aimerais bien qu'on y pense voilà le
message est passé moi je vois là quand
j'ai quelque chose à dire je n'en
déplaise
en tout cas en tout cas réjouissons-nous
qui est plus en plus de femmes auteures
dans le cinéma parce que c'est bon ben
il ya fort à parier que ça va
bouleverser les codes que les les films
vont vraiment changer d'angle les
comédies romantiques aussi vont beaucoup
changer et je jusqu'au jour où peut-être
ce sera à saly qui rencontrera harry